[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission nous
allons parler de littérature et plus
particulièrement de littérature
européenne avec mon invité Katarina loix
von ouf bonjour enchanté de vous
recevoir bonjour merci de me recevoir
alors vous êtes la fondatrice d'une
maison d'édition qui s'appelle les
Argonautes qui est toute récente qui a
son siège à Saint-Germain-en-Laye oui
tout à fait moi je vis je suis allemande
comme vous entendez peut-être à mon
accent
ça fait 20 ans que je vis en France et
je me suis installé il y a 10 ans à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc c'est
naturellement là dans cette endroit
assez international que je voulais
installer ma nouvelle maison d'édition
qui est c'est vrai que c'est une ville
assez internationale d'ailleurs
[Musique]
donc on va parler évidemment de cette
maison d'édition les Argonautes et des
premières publications qui sont les
vôtres un mot d'abord sur un peu votre
parcours vous le disiez vous êtes vous
êtes vous avez été autrice
j'étais autrice en Allemagne autrice et
éditrice et dans un ancien enfin
beaucoup plus il y a plus beaucoup plus
longtemps j'étais journaliste aussi et
quand je suis quand je me suis installé
en France j'ai un peu abandonné le
journaliste pour donc écrire mon premier
roman et puis pour
en allemand seulement il n'a pas été
traduit peut-être
non et donc c'est voilà je suis je suis
devenu d'abord tout d'abord agent
littéraire
ça m'intéresse parce que
en France on a découvert les agents
littéraires mais il y a pas si longtemps
que ça c'était c'était quelque chose de
courant aux États-Unis notamment tous
les grands auteurs américains avaient
des agents littéraires en France c'était
plutôt les maisons d'édition elle-même
qui s'occupaient des auteurs et puis
sont arrivés des injures littéraires
alors en quoi ça consiste
tout à fait donc ce qui existe depuis
longtemps c'était les sous agents donc
les coûts agents existaient déjà pour
vendre les droits de traduction ça
c'était mon métier donc c'était c'était
des agences sur place qui vendaient des
droits de traduction des éditeurs
américains
que dans la plupart du temps où aussi
allemand ou asiatique aux éditeurs
français donc ce n'est pas le travail
directement avec les auteurs ce qui
assez nouveau c'est que les Français
aussi s'occupent des agents qu'on
appelle direct vraiment littéraire et
c'était le cas de ma de ma de ma
patronne
anajarotha et johnsi qui qui était
notamment la la jambe directe de Valérie
Trierweiler pour nommer le projet le
plus le plus le plus
voilà il était traduit
tout à fait tout à fait et puis elle
était aussi mais elle est aussi l'agent
de Catherine Pancol par exemple donc
elle a quelques projets mais moi je
m'occupais de la vente de droit de
traduction donc aux Etats
extrêmement important pour la pour la
littérature et c'est là que ce nous
alors les éditeurs arrivent avec avec
des quelque part de délivre et puis
voilà on les vaut pour pour l'export si
je peux dire pour tout à fait c'est là
où je profite de mon ancien métier
d'agent de je les contacts dans le monde
entier donc
pour avoir été à Francfort depuis 10-15
ans maintenant donc j'ai des contacts
qui me permettent maintenant de trouver
les voiles les plus intéressantes dans
le monde entier donc ça c'est vrai c'est
très alléchant voilà alors donc agent
littéraire et puis après vous entrez
dans une très grande maison d'édition
qui est Gallimard où vous vous occupez
du secteur de la littérature étrangère
tout à fait j'étais responsable du
service littérature étrangère donc j'ai
coordonné les publications et je me suis
occupée directement des langues un peu
autre pour lesquels il n'y avait pas de
spécialiste dans la maison donc je me
suis occupé en tant que spécialiste
l'allemand de la littérature le monde
merci de la littérature néerlandaise
israélienne
asiatique
arabe donc j'ai eu comme ça beaucoup de
territoires que desquels je me suis
c'est vrai que quand on dit littérature
étrangère on pense essentiellement quand
en France à la littérature anglo-saxonne
qui qui prend une grande part de marché
je suppose de la oui c'est en fait 75%
des romans traduits en français sont
traduit de l'anglais c'est c'est moi en
tant éditrice donc des grands auteurs
comme
européen Facebook
trading enfin Stéphane Hartman la
Belgique j'avais des auteurs européens
qui avaient beaucoup de succès chez
Karima donc qui était très émis par le
public les autorités
c'est des grands succès et c'est la
littérature européenne mais le préjugé
normalement c'est que ça marche pas
c'est cher c'est compliqué enfin voilà
quand même alors
c'est vrai que des auteurs italiens vous
en avez cité il y en a espagnol depuis
Cervantes quand même
l'Italie depuis dedans et puis et puis
on découvert un peu
souvent à travers les polars comme
millidium la littérature scandinave ces
dernières années tout à fait tout à fait
on découvre et je pense que mes on n'est
pas conscient que ça soit là et que ça
ça forme un ensemble c'est à dire
patrimoine culturel européen et
je pense qu'on est tellement maintenant
habitué à la culture américaine ou
anglo-saxonne tout court que que là on
sait tout donc c'est il n'y a plus de
barrières culturels à casser pendant que
pour des auteurs Croates ou même
allemand ou roumain il y a toujours une
barrière culturelle à traverser et quand
un auteur est grand on se rend même plus
compte qu'il est européen on se dit ah
oui quand même c'est un mauvais donc
voilà ça dépasse ça et il faut dire
aussi que même si les Français sont
absolument nuls en langue étrangère
un peu l'anglais beaucoup moins
l'allemand je parle pas du norvégien du
scandinaves il y a ça aussi mais
peut-être
tradition de pas trop se tourner vers
les langues étrangères peut-être mais je
pense que c'est en train de changer
comme
la génération
Erasmus il y a des liens qui se sont
créés en Europe qui sont très forts il y
a beaucoup de
gens comme moi qui adorent vivre en
France et qui sont étrangères
c'est quand même quelque chose qui fait
que moi je pense déjà il y a un intérêt
à s'entretien à la littérature
européenne parce que c'est important de
mieux connaître l'autre et de mieux
voilà de mieux se connaître
c'est important pour moi
tout court mais deuxièmement il y a
aussi ces liens qui se sont créés ces
derniers femmes 30 ans qui ont vraiment
changé la donne un changement alors
les argots dans cette vidéo les
Argonautes puisque c'est le le nom de
votre maison d'édition alors évidemment
les Argonautes références à la
mythologie grecque c'est du compagnon de
Jason qui sont le sur le bateau argot
qui vont chercher la Toison d'or mais
évidemment pour vous je pense que c'est
vous allez me dire je pense pas que j'ai
pas pensé est-ce que c'est une référence
au fond au fait que la culture
européenne elle doit beaucoup
essentiellement à à la Grèce oui c'est
tout d'abord c'est un hommage aux grands
épiques
mythologies qui nous qui nourrissent
notre culture jusqu'à nos jours mais
deuxièmement c'est aussi un petit clin
d'oeil parce que je trouve que cette
histoire de de enfin il y a beaucoup de
versions de l'histoire de des agonautes
mais il y a parfois 70 ou 80 hommes il y
a même une femme à Talente qui qui
s'aventure sur ce bateau qui qui
c'est un mythe et c'est quelque chose
c'est un peu
presque rigolo parce que je pense que
personne ne sait ce que c'est vraiment
le Toison d'or c'est quelque chose de
très abstrait et finalement assez vent
et pour moi c'est masculin et viril et
un peu un peu voilà moi clin d'oeil
aussi
je me suis dit voilà et j'ai mis une
femme cela le logo sur notre logo pour
pour faire pour prendre sa très claire
que voilà on met à jour un peu le mythe
et mon Toison d'or c'est c'est
évidemment de faire une sorte puzzle de
ces grandes voiles de la littérature
européenne pour pour créer un ensemble
qui nous fait rêver l'aventure le voyage
la rencontre de l'autre est-ce que vous
direz qu'il y a derrière qui a parce que
évidemment il y a beaucoup de différence
peut-être mais est-ce qu'il y a est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui fait
culture commune dans la littérature
européenne est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose de commun selon vous oui tout
d'abord c'est certainement la diversité
la richesse cette culture très donc on a
en Europe on a quand même tous les tous
les 100 km on a parfois une langue une
culture extrêmement différente donc
c'est très c'est très très riche en
diversité
et deuxièmement c'est cette histoire
très très forte et très marquante des
deux dernières guerre mondiales et
cette recherche de la mémoire aussi de
d'une culture comment là où tout se
mélange je pense que dans cette région
du balcon ou même l'Europe centrale
l'Europe de l'Est c'est vraiment
un mélange de culture qui est très
intense et qui très qui peut créer des
conflits très rapidement mais qui mène
aussi à vivre ensemble magnifique
il y a aussi la construction européenne
aussi
on verra que l'Europe c'est pas enfin
l'Europe de la culture n'est pas ne
correspond pas dans les frontières aux
frontières tout à fait
on peut aller sur votre site vous avez
un site qui est extrêmement bien fait et
il y a dedans par exemple une carte
interactive enfin une carte dire qu'elle
est interactif plus tard dans lesquelles
voilà il y a plein de petites drapeaux
et on clique sur les drapeaux on voit
bah la plupart des des auteurs
européens selon les pays dans la Suède
au Norvège en Italie en Grèce etc et
donc il suffit de cliquer on tombe sur
les livres où est-ce qu'il y a c'est pas
forcément des livres que vous publiez
vous c'est des références et des livres
qui sont dans chez d'autres éditeurs
et et alors c'est absolument formidable
parce que
la carte je disais elle est interactive
c'est à dire ce sont les lecteurs qu'il
a qui la remplissent c'est ça pour
l'instant c'est surtout moi et mon
équipe
on l'encourage beaucoup les lecteurs les
traducteurs les spécialistes les
éditeurs aussi tout le monde qui aime et
qui soutient cette littérature
européenne d'ajouter les livres c'est
possible elle est interactive voilà si
si j'ai découvert un livre alors je sais
pas moi j'ai cliqué sur l'Ukraine par
exemple j'ai vu le livre d'entrée
qui est publié chez Diana Lévy qui
s'appelle les abeilles grises alors si
on s'intéresse à faire du Dombas voilà
c'est une c'est ce qu'il faut dire on
Norvège justement sur les invisibles de
Roy Jacobson par exemple c'est vrai que
c'est formidable parce que là il y a des
livres beaucoup de loups qu'on a pas lu
évidemment qu'on peut découvrir grâce à
cette carte qui se trouve sur votre site
autre chose alors qu'il m'a son
formidable aussi sur ce site
c'est les cases classiques de la
littérature européenne à lire absolument
ça c'est formidable parce que alors on
peut on peut fêter comme ça évidemment
ça commence par le Docteur Jivago oui
évidemment
un livre que je connaissais pas moi la
place du diamant de de mercerie rodo
Reda oui tout à fait donc il y a
vraiment ça ce sont ce sont pas des
livres que tout le monde connaît on a on
s'est vraiment efforcé de regarder un
peu plus loin et de de révéler les
pépites que qui pourrait qui pourrait
amener à des vrais découvertes mais ce
sont à chaque fois des grands classiques
c'est un homme de de primovie aussi le
désert des tartares le guépard donc des
livres
que des gens connaissent je sais pas si
ils sont évidemment si classique et puis
et puis des découvertes
par exemple je sais pas beagle de macda
Zabou qui est roi c'est un livre sur une
petite fille qui est caché qui a envoyé
par son père dans un internat et elle
sait pas ce qui lui arrive et elle est
extrêmement fâchée contre son père et il
s'avère à la fin c'est que c'était pour
la cacher
quand les nazis
et à chercher les Juifs et que elle
était cachée
c'est un plutôt un livre culte que un
grand classique peut-être mais c'est en
train de devenir un classique donc ce
que je sais faire
moi je dirais oui les 15 livres qu'il
faut lire si on s'intéresse à la
littérature européenne et c'est très
très bien fait alors il y a aussi le le
fidèle Rousselon alors ça c'est sur les
sur le goulag
en Russie
il y a
Zorba oui elle existe Zorba c'est zorbel
grec c'est la même chose
de la littérature de qui après est
devenu ce film fameux donc oui le livre
s'appelle Alexis Zorba et le film Grecs
c'est pour ça qu'on connaît
là on se rend quand même bien compte de
du poids de l'histoire dans dans la
littérature européenne mais aussi aussi
de cette voilà destin féminins comme
mercure odorida et d'autres Maria cadoso
qui donc
est portugaise et
c'est la littérature catalane donc ce
sont deux femmes qui ont souffert
de la guerre de
mouvement historiques et politiques de
du monde et c'est l'heure c'est qui
racontait c'est extrêmement fort aussi
donc et si je reviens vous parlez tout à
l'heure de la littérature nordique il y
a ce rendez-vous qui était un
best-seller le livre de Vatanen c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique on a même
fait toute une une série de
recommandations de livres qui qui met en
tant que protagoniste des des animaux
parce que c'est très sympa donc c'est un
journaliste qui trouve un lapin et qui
au lieu de continuer sa vie continue sa
vie avec les lapins donc c'est très très
charmant ce qui est génial non parce que
je trouve très beau formidable c'est que
sur ce site de de mes auditions les
Argonautes voilà c'est ça prouve votre
générosité c'est ce que c'est votre but
c'est voilà de promouvoir au fond la
littérature européenne qui va au-delà
même je disais de votre propre
publication alors vos publications on y
arrive ça commence c'est tout récent de
sa date de maintenant
le premier c'est marrant de mort la
Vierge néerlandaise
oui tout à fait vous avez des versions
originales je crois j'ai ici là je vais
vous montrer aussi c'est voilà oui c'est
un roman qui a été traduit en 17 langues
et qui qui
vraiment désormais en quelque sorte un
classique aussi parce que ça fait il a
été écrit en 2010 mais il n'a jamais été
traduit en français pour l'instant et
chaque année il y a une traduction qui
se rajoute dans le monde donc chaque
année il y a un éditeur qui le découvre
moi je l'ai découvert parce qu'il y
avait une critique dans New York Times
qui disait que c'était le meilleur livre
que la critique avait lu toute cette
année je me suis dit ça doit être
quelque chose
et c'est vrai que elle a une longue
magnifique et que c'est justement elle
va justement chercher une histoire assez
historique donc c'est le seul endroit
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille parce
que je l'ai pas
c'est une jeune fille il y en a qui a 18
ans et qui qui passionnait d'escrime on
voit cela couverture et c'est dans
l'entre-deux-guerres donc dans les
années 30 dans 1936 elle est envoyée
pendant l'été par son père chez un ami
en Allemagne à travers la frontière il
s'avère que cet ami c'est un grand
maître d'escrime d'aristocrate qui vit
sur un beau une belle propriété
se rappelle ça rappelle un peu d'affre
de mourir peut-être
il est abîmé c'est assez il a des
problèmes de la guerre donc c'est un
grand hussard une salle de corps
allemand qui vit toujours dans ce monde
d'honneur d'amitié les codes d'honneur
très très fort de de l'avant guerre et
qui qui a le plus grand mal avec ce
nouveau monde qui s'approche c'est à
dire les nazis la barbarisme le barbarie
de cette de cette manque de culture
justement et
voilà et cette jeune fille découvre
en passant les frontières et ça c'est
très très bien fait très intelligent et
pas cela frontière elle passe la
frontière vers l'âge adulte elle elle
découvre cette demande des adultes plein
de mensonges de donneur de faux honneur
de et justement de violence des nazis
qui approchent c'est très marrant alors
je suis c'est votre première publication
il y a déjà une part dans le monde des
livres sur ce livre donc voilà
c'est la preuve que
j'avais fait un très bon choix oui je
cherche vraiment des auteurs qui ont
tous déjà des grands Grands Prix dans
leur pays d'origine qui ont largement
traduits donc c'est vraiment je cherche
vraiment la qualité les pépites les
traducteurs c'est difficile à trouver
beaucoup de traducteurs de néerlandais
par exemple
on a une grande qualité donc c'est très
donc le pays fait une politique
culturelle on va la littérature très
très forte et donc il y a moi je connais
6 traductrices qui sont formidables
après je veux pas les autres je les
connais pas mais c'est vraiment une
qualité
vous me dites voilà le le le journal
américain disent c'est c'est le plus
gros roman de l'année enfin c'est un
très gros roman et et le fait que vous
soyez une jeune maison d'édition ça ça
ils vous ont accordé leur confiance
c'est quand même formidable ça dépend
c'est pas facile c'est très difficile
donc en ce moment oui il faut que je me
batte et en ce moment je perds encore
beaucoup d'enchères parce qu'à chaque
fois que moi je trouve une pépite je
fais une offre à l'agence voilà ça monte
et moi j'ai pas beaucoup de fond je suis
indépendante donc c'est ma propre
dès qu'il y a un grand éditeur qui saute
sur le projet ce qui arrive souvent moi
je perds en général mais je connais ces
gens les amis
personnel et je pense que ça va bientôt
devenir plus facile alors donc marin de
mort la Vierge néerlandaise ça c'est
paru déjà à part début février tout
début février tout à fait pas steam
c'est très c'est très difficile à
prononcer c'est un auteur en fait qui
finlandais mais qui qui d'origine
albanaise donc il vient du Cosmo quand
il avait deux ans ses parents ont fui la
gare au Kosovo il y avait ces conflits
entre les ethnies et l'auteur il est
vraiment d'une famille des migrants il a
fait énorme carrière parce qu'il vient
de recevoir pour ce livre le prix
Finlandia donc c'est l'équivalent du
prix Goncourt en Finlande donc moi je
trouve déjà vraiment et le plus jeune
auteur à l'avoir jamais oui
il n'avait même pas 30 ans quand il a
reçu ce prix et c'est quand même déjà
une carrière remarquable il enseigne la
littérature comparée à l'université de
Helsinki et donc pas trop tu as déjà été
publié en France avec deux romans mais
il n'a pas été prévu donc ce que je
voudrais faire c'est vous c'est dire
voilà c'est un auteur énorme
vous avez l'intention de publier combien
de de de romans par an donc cette année
ce seront seulement 6 parce qu'il faut
que je non
parce que ce que vous faites aussi c'est
vous occuper de ces auteurs c'est vrai
que si on a 200 c'est pas pareil
bénéficier et après je vais augmenter au
fur et à mesure à 10 12 livres par an
certainement pas plus parce qu'on est
vraiment une petite équipe et comme vous
dites il faut que je m'occupe
personnellement
de alors
on passe ça c'est quoi mode de mars non
c'est une jeune autrice danoise
ou tout à fait
de l'argent
là c'est encore les preuves au nom
corrigées
c'est le troisième et c'est une jeune
autrice qui est incroyable ça c'est le
premier d'une série de 7 cette livre
qu'elle va écrire qu'elle est en train
d'écrire sur le thème de quoi autour
d'une d'une catastrophe de de
l'incendie volontaire d'une ferry d'une
fairy low cost de la scandinave and
Starking peut-être se rappeler encore
cette cette histoire donc
c'était pour récupérer l'agent de
l'assurance qu'ils ont mis feu à une
ferry low cost et il y a 150 personnes
qui ont trouvé la mort c'était pas
c'était pas voulu par ceux qui ont juste
l'argent mais c'est un quatrième typique
de de pour l'autrice tellement typique
du capitalisme qui qui rend sa possible
donc c'est une jeune autrice qui qui
férocement attaque le capitalisme et
c'est très étonnant parce qu'elle a elle
raconte une histoire extrêmement
poétique d'un couple un peu modeste donc
courte et Maggie qui se rencontrent à
une soirée arrosée et qui au Danemark et
qui mène leur vie d'une manière
extrêmement difficile qui sont dans
l'échec social mais vraiment total et
c'est c'est
poétique c'est dur c'est c'est très beau
aussi
et
donc
c'est tout un coup on raconte en cette
histoire tout un coup elle a dit mais
attendez et là il y a un lien parce que
il y a cet incendie du fer du ferry
scanner et elle touche ce drame et il
montre comment tous les problèmes
sociaux d'une société peuvent être liées
peuvent se retrouver comme comme le
destin de ces deux personnes et
finalement assez
assez préparé en avance
l'histoire évidemment il y a le
capitalisme enfin les l'économie en fait
toutes ces recommandations qui sont
celles de tous les Européens tout à fait
et puis on Scandinavie il y a cette
grande la grande tradition du roman
social donc c'est c'est vraiment je pour
moi c'était ça aussi qui m'a intéressé
là-dedans c'est l'autrice suit aussi un
peu cette voilà une critique sociale ou
politique assez forte
on va suivre comme ça vous venez quand
vous voulez
c'est parce que c'est le celui qui est
actuellement en vente de mort la Vierge
néerlandaise voilà formidable voilà
c'est quel journal américain dit c'est
le New York Times
le monde l'a dit aussi donc je pense
également une personne
Catalina merci infiniment et à très vite
j'espère pour vous parler de de votre
maison d'édition et de littérature
européenne merci
[Musique]